foreign
[Music]
ER Jen Wilson and welcome to this film
independent independent presents q a for
the HBO documentary the fastest woman on
Earth
by Graham swarsa and Christopher ottwell
a special thanks to lead sponsor hefka
and our virtual screenings partner
Vision media
and now please welcome our guests the
directors of the fastest woman on earth
Graham sorset and Christopher otwell
yeah thank you
um so we uh at film Independence
um our a lot of many of our members are
aspiring filmmakers
um we're aspiring to do other things in
the film industry
can you suit to sort of
um give this a glimpse into how you got
into filmmaking um we'll start with
Graham
sure
um so it started young I mean uh from an
early age we were the first house on the
Block to have a video camera it was when
they were Tethered to a vcr and you had
to kind of like haul the thing around
and and it was a two-part camera we were
the very last house to have a microwave
but somehow you know Cameron was a was
the first thing in our family and from a
young age I just really loved finding
perspective and capturing moments and
um so you know went to film school and
even through that was looking to tell
stories about travel you know I had
spent time in Africa and wanted to bring
home kind of stories from the the remote
village where I was staying
um and I interviewed for a job once and
they said you know it was for an
automotive
um kind of car series and they said have
you ever shot a car going 60 miles an
hour around the canyon and I said no but
I've shot a cheetah on the Savannah
running 60 miles chasing a gazelle and
said okay great you've got the job
it kind of veered off into this
Automotive World which as you can
imagine you know with this film kind of
took
um Us in in that action adventure
um path and and Chris and I through that
um started working together and and
formed a really deep partnership as a
result
foreign
making a movie in your bedroom or
whatever
um
yeah kind of kind of a similar you know
you pick up a camera and it just feels
natural the storytelling felt natural I
grew up with movies and and so yeah it
was sort of in my bones I was a theater
kid
uh I went and got a film degree and um
at Florida State
and came out of Florida State making
movies on 16 millimeter you know
spending a a fortune making really bad
movies you know uh this was ahead of a
digital Revolution you know and so it's
been kind of an amazing thing to watch
the tools change in such a way that you
can you can make legit movies for next
to nothing now and
we couldn't before
um what I learned through that process
was that I wasn't a great screenwriter I
was under the illusion that I was a kind
of on tour I was going to write my own
stories and direct and and just control
everything and edit and all of that and
I I discovered that I was really lousy
screenwriter and and I was much better
at telling stories that were taken from
reality stories that actually happened
to people I knew stories that happened
to me and uh much like Graham going off
and finding adventure to me the
documentary filmmaking was an extension
of
um if there's not a story for me to tell
right from me I'm gonna go live one
you know I mean I'm gonna pick up my
camera and I'm gonna go you know
Step Beyond my boundaries out into the
world and and and hope that something
interesting happens uh and Graham has a
great expression doing Automotive uh uh
uh material where he says um you know
any car is exciting at its limit whether
you're in a Lamborghini or and you're
like a 3200 bucket any car at its limit
is is dramatic right so same thing with
lives anybody pushing their own limits
anybody kind of stepping beyond their
Norm
um there's a story there you know and we
all hopefully you know touch that every
day in some some small way you know and
just to add on that that's an important
point for our filmmaking culture I think
is we expect that and encourage that
with our team and our crew members you
know what do you want to learn today
what can you what limits can you push
today because if we're all growing and
learning there's no blame there's only
support right
um if someone is you know someone's out
on the skinny branches for their ability
or their their instinct or you know
experience uh you create a culture of
support rather than blame and and shame
you know and so it really we find that
that's that's a huge part of our team
culture as filmmakers we were shooting
an episode of the list which is the show
where we met Jesse and and Graham and I
collaborated on the show you know we
were in England
shooting at the um asking shot where
they restore all the the old original
Bond Aston Martins and stuff and and we
shot a cool episode there and
pulled in with our usual method and our
usual Vibe and our team is very tight we
travel and it's like a family and so we
just bring our method to it and at the
end of it they were like we've never
dealt with the crew that didn't just
scream at each other for 45 minutes
before they started shooting you know
like this British Union crew Crews rule
in and they just have to debate the heck
out of everything before anything
happens and we were just so cash and
hopefully left everybody better than we
found them yeah and then at the end of
the day they were very very happy with
the uh with the material we created too
so yeah so uh so you mentioned that you
worked on uh uh Jesse's show is is that
part of how you came to make this film
about her yeah so I was hired uh wow 12
15 years ago 12 plus years ago to create
a series it was called the list a
thousand one car things to do before you
die and it was originally intended to be
a car show for Car Guys
and that just felt really real you know
and and so we said well what if it's
what if it's a um what if the expert is
a woman who is like deep in this field
and it's a action-adventure series
rather than a car show I mean it's more
accessible when we think are you a car
guy or not it's it's kind of like well
for me that means like a tank of gas and
some time and some friends like yeah I'm
a car guy I want to go on a road trip I
want to seek Adventure that was always
the thing that like
thrusts you through the world right and
so that's that's the intention we set
out with but so intentionally we were
looking to to
um
audition women to be the expert on the
team and Jesse walked into the audition
um we had kind of known about her from
her previous TV experience on Overhaulin
and she was on MythBusters for a while
and she walked in the room and it was
just like magnetic she just had energy
and personality and and most importantly
experience deep experience Hands-On
welding
um great mechanic great Builder
fabricator she just was the real deal
and you know and we chose Jesse and as
the host of the show and what we come to
find out and what anyone that knows her
he finds out is that she actually
chooses you right like she's auditioning
you she's vetting you and and and and
um she chose us and and and so to kind
of complete the the cycle about two
years into the show
she came to me and said you know Graham
I have this opportunity
um I don't know what it means for this
show but I'm wondering if it could maybe
be a part of it I was invited to be The
Driver of the North American Eagle land
speed car and they're looking to break
the world record
um the female land speed record which
has been in place since 1976 and it's
something I think I want to do
and so she pursued that on her own and
kind of caught her own bug with with how
she wanted that to express itself in the
world for being a mentor for young women
and we went
um we we got permission to follow and
and film her first attempts to at the
land speed record in 2013.
and when Chris and I hit the lake bed
for the first time to see this 12 mile
expanse of pure flat Playa and this car
built from a repurposed fighter jet from
the 50s and this team of like volunteer
engineers and and and Aviation
enthusiasts it was like
this is happening in one place on the
planet with one team with this one woman
and it just so happens that that we're
all in this together and it was like
it was a paradigm shift in kind of that
when that story and World presents
itself to you
you know you you keep going
so how do you actually film something
like this like what are the conditions
out in the Albert desert in Oregon where
they were doing these
um speed tests
the Alvord is the first thing to know
about it is that it's it's
a hundred miles from the closest
civilization and we use the term loosely
I mean it's in the middle of nowhere
it's very hard to get to it's like a
solid 15 16 hours of driving from from
Los Angeles
um and so
you know it it might as well be Nepal or
or Africa or I mean it feels very very
remote very much on an expedition uh
there are very few Services out there
there's a hot spring
um because the the land is very volcanic
out there
um it's on the Pacific Rim you know if
you look at a map of Oregon it's all
these volcanoes that kind of dot the
land and it's it's sort of in that line
and and so
there's this incredible
kind of mysterious energy to the place
because it is very you know tectonically
active and and you know water boils up
from underneath and there's a ten
thousand foot mountains Dean's Mountain
it's literally ten thousand feet on your
left and to the right it's like four
thousand feet so it's a six thousand
foot differential and so it's just very
extreme the weather reflects that
um it you know it can be very hot and
and dry one day and the next day clouds
roll in and you think oh my God it's
gonna rain and when it does rain it
turns the the surface to Absolute muck
and you can't accomplish anything and
yeah um the the the seasonal kind of uh
variations out there are always why the
teams are up against very limited
windows that they can accomplish this
feat because there's only certain
Seasons you can go permitting is very
difficult
um you know it's um the condition of the
lake band obviously varies from year to
year and some years you just can't do it
literally there were years we were like
are we going out this year like nope
sand is too soft like come back next
year yeah and it distorts yourself just
like the space of the place the sorts
your sense of scale right the Endeavor
distorts your sense of time like once a
lot of time to think we're going to
accomplish this goal like we had to
completely recalibrate like our concept
of how long it would take and from a
from a filmmaking standpoint a capture
standpoint you know I I think I would I
would narrow it down to three or four
main factors which which are
you know you've got a 12 mile expanse
that you need to cover when that car
leaves mile zero it's going 8 to 12
miles down down range right uh at you
know 400 plus 500 plus miles an hour and
so what takes her a couple minutes to
get down there uh takes us if we went
100 miles an hour it's a 12 minute drive
right to go get her
um to meet up with her so coverage right
you can have people at Mile zero you can
have people at As She Drives By maybe a
drone in the air and people at the end
but otherwise it's catch us cash can
um the dust the talcum powder kind of
Playa dust gets in everything and it
will stay in everything forever if
anyone's been to Burning Man or you know
uh it that's it it's got that that
tingle to it you know you've touched
something that was on the plyo and your
fingers start to tingle so it it gets on
the um they're all completely gray when
we walk away I've got a great picture of
Graham and he's
and now I'm great for different reasons
but
and then and then the camera's in the
car right uh for us it was extremely
important and this is where we leaned on
our Automotive experience
um and an action adventure
um
filmmaking
filming is that those cameras had to be
secure our cameras could not be the
reason something went wrong in that
cockpit when they came undone or
um or fell or were in her line of sight
or anything and so we were really
conscientious about where we placed
cameras and how safe they were and even
still the vibration in that vehicle at
those speeds was unthreading the
um the rigging you know all the hardware
we could throw and everything in there
slowly turned and and uh it actually
became part of the creative just to show
that like the forces at work in this
endeavor are the failure of the canvas
it's much the same when you're trying to
budget like that at 500 miles an hour on
a 500 millimeter lens half a mile away
I got it I got it oh I lost it it's gone
and then in an instant you have to catch
up so there's that moment where the
camera catches up to it because the
thing is too fast for any camera
operator and the vibrations are too
strong for any camera reading so again
the limits are where it's exciting right
you know and a lot of that makes the cut
these imperfections where things fail
it's like it just kind of shows you the
forces it were it feels like very high
stakes filmmaking also because you can't
you can't say hey let's do another take
yeah something like that
I noticed there was some aerial was that
all done with drones or did you have
helicopter planes or so the first year
the team had a partner come out in a
helicopter and that's the thing this
whole team was in there it was a fixed
Wing plane yeah oh that's right that's
right
um so given that this team is in the
aviation field I mean they have friends
flying out and dropping down on the lake
bed and so there were just planes around
that would stop in to visit to us that
was you know just kind of Novel but yeah
um wolf Aviation
um a a company out of La that that does
um
um
aerial videography filmmaking things
like that they were out uh as a means of
supporting the team and they filmed um
in 2013 and then in subsequent years we
we brought drones out and we're filming
um yeah it's an interesting distinction
between the two the the fixed-wing
aircraft gave us a speed that you can't
get with a drone the Drone you know is
drones are great but they only travel so
fast and so far
and uh there's I mean even even the
full-on aircraft is not going to keep up
with this this car on the ground but in
in flying sort of parallel with it and
letting it pass it created some really
interesting Dynamics whereas a drone
you're just kind of parked and the car
goes by and it's you know you're kind of
limited with how you can track it so
that was an interesting you know thing
to learn about
uh so early on we sort of you know
viewed the history of the the supersonic
the the race to
um you know build the fastest car and
and do the fastest ride and so the it
was the
it was the Brits with their Supersonic
car that went was it 800
miles per hour
763 was their official number yeah and
just looking at that footage I'm like
okay
this car and this team and all of it
looks like it's an Elon Musk type uh
situation with a lot of money and so
it's very astute by the way yeah thank
you yeah when you're looking at the
situation with uh Jesse's team
um
and a lot of it being you know they
didn't have a lot of funding and they're
just like converting you know a jet
plane and getting like volunteered I'm
just like this is absolutely crazy
did you feel that did you feel like why
do these people want to do that what do
you think attracts them to do this
the word we're constantly coming to is
audacity the audacity of this dream to
think that it's even possible that this
could be done uh the history of land
speed racing is generally like pretty
well-funded well-sponsored teams Craig
Breedlove in the 60s had good years
sponsoring his runs they would camp out
from months out at Bonneville and like
the resources were really piled into it
because people were paying attention and
even as late as the 90s somebody was
still watching when this thing was going
on and so the the the
um the English government actually
supports the the land speed initiative
as a kind of um Science Education
mathematics
research and education initiative so
there's a lot of Public Funding in it
matched with private it's complicated
but um a lot of a lot of money put into
it and and these guys yeah they they
they were building a car and then and
when the Brits went supersonic their car
was just junk they couldn't use it
anymore and so suddenly these drag
racers are like well how do we take that
step into this stratospheric you know
realm that we haven't even touched it we
don't have the money we don't have the
technology we were building it from
scratch and this just one moment of what
if yeah from Ed like what if we took
this perfect old plane you know without
putting the Wings off and put wheels on
I mean it's it's like it's asinine
yeah and they were at it for you know 15
plus years prior to us even stepping
foot into their world and when the car
runs it's like it's a miracle that this
part is what it does
I think the sponsorship conversation
here is the filmmaking conversation
right because Chris and I reached out
maybe you know to to seek funding and a
couple years into the process and it's
like okay well how long is it going to
take we don't know
how much is it going to cost we don't
know call us when it's done right and
and so same for sponsorship for this
team it was or any team pursuing this
which there's only two others in the
world that we know of but um yeah you
you get one shot a year it costs a ton
of money to go out and do it production
and you know right you're you're just
like one go here we go
um and if it fails it's another year of
tweaking tinkering in the whole thing
but yeah this team the knowledge and
heart
um they're all you know engineers and
navy Builders and they all have the
skill
and under Ed's leadership
um
they all made this happen and it's just
incredible they've got a lot to be proud
of for for what they're actually able to
accomplish over the years
I think it's uh it's um it's both an
aviation mentality and a racist
mentality this idea that give me a roll
of duct tape and some JB Weld and we can
make this thing go
um
and and then the the military you know
these guys are a lot of them are
ex-military and certainly ex-military
there's the sense of the mission has to
be accomplished there you know failure
is not an option like whatever you must
bring to it you you have to and when you
put that those two sensibilities
together
then things actually happen and then
people start to believe and now you have
a group that's believing I mean it gets
exponentially more effective and and
that's kind of where we stepped in the
team had been testing the car and
building the car for like 15 years by
the time we actually saw it run the
first time so we got to show up and be
awestruck by it yeah and not really know
all the details of what went into it but
once you find out how audacious the
stream was it's uh um
you know
uh as so you know I'm a person who's
like uh not a Gearhead but I my my whole
entire family are NASCAR fans and and
Gearheads my dad and my brother love
cars and motorcycles and
um so they you know watch a lot of this
and so watching this I think
that um it was hard for me to Fathom
just how dangerous everything really was
because you have this concept that
they're out in the desert where there's
miles and miles and miles nothing so
what's she gonna crash into or you know
what's really going to be the danger so
I feel like I was pretty shocked
um when the end came and she actually
did die
um
can you talk about what did you have a
concept of that was like a large
possibility when you were making this
film
yeah when we went out in 2013 we were
oblivious to this whole thing it was
like oh these guys are Pros they've got
it handled the car is great everything's
going to be great what could go wrong
but it's it's a weird thing that happens
too with um
you know in life our minds do this thing
where we envision the worst
so that we can file it away and put it
behind us like your kid running out into
the street right as soon as they can
walk it's like you envision them running
out in the street and you kind of file
that
and that's what happened in 2013 when I
first saw that car go in my brain I saw
it kite and kind of take off and just go
catastrophic
and then when we drove the 10 miles to
get to her and she's there Smiles that
the engine's cooling down the whole
thing was just like oh okay follow that
away
um
it was always a possibility and the
stakes were always high but on that
particular run that you're talking about
you know my experience was coming down
the lake bed to find her to reveal that
reality had kind of jumped the tracks
into that first scenario that I saw many
years ago in 2013 in my mind
and all I could say was okay okay
you know okay I've seen this before
I knew it was a possibility and I can't
actually process it in this moment
it was definitely
a State of Shock
um in
kind of having that be a reality and
having to immediately
face it and come to terms with the fact
that it had actually happened and not
knowing the outcome so still in my mind
I saw the team you know with the like
soldier carry with her arms over two
people walking away from the scene or
I've envisioned me visiting her in the
hospital sitting bedside going oh my God
that was crazy you know you hold on to
this stuff as long as you can until you
actually find uh the truth yeah I kept
telling myself that uh Kitty O'Neill
survived a crash hit 300 some odd miles
an hour and that was foremost in my mind
when when we didn't know what had
happened on that run it was like oh
Kitty Kitty made it out so it was kind
of
holding on to that
um and in that sense
you can't show up and film the 15 or
however many runs we had done you know
prior to that without every time
flipping that switch and saying No this
is gonna be okay this is gonna be okay
It's gotta be it's good and Jesse speaks
to that in the movie you can't you can't
get in to do these things without you
know the risk it's there
you file it and and you you have to
believe deep down that like it's gonna
be okay yeah we're watching the movie a
second time uh the scene where
um Jesse asked Kitty
um you know why did you quit why did you
stop doing it and kitty says too many of
my friends died
and I was just like
the four boat I didn't realize like that
before but it's like wow yeah I'm glad
you watched it again because it is you
know that's i i i there is so much in
there throughout the whole film that
that you know I I hope that people do
watch it multiple times because it only
serves to have you appreciate the
choices she made the whole way of step
in lean in step in Empower face you know
face fears be courageous it only makes
her more powerful knowing
the full cycle she traveled
yeah I think it's um when you watch
something like Nascar or formula one or
any of these other things that people
are watching now it's easy to forget
that aspect yeah so easy to forget how
how extremely dangerous it really is
yeah well
um yeah sorry sorry I was gonna say I
think things with Motorsports and racing
you know everyone wants to go am I a car
person or not and and and what we've
found is it's it's really the human
behind the wheel that these are people
that want to iterate and be better and
they're they're they're
um
uh fanatical about Improvement and
betterment and and uh technique and and
so the racing part is just how it
expresses itself you know a lot of these
people if it expressed itself in other
ways in the world it would be through
ART or music or something else like you
know Jesse did leather work and uh
building motorcycles and welding and
fabricating it's like she was just
always about being better than she was
yesterday and being an example for
others that because she in her words was
average if I can do it you can too and
so
I think it's just you know we really
grew to understand
racing as really an expression of people
just wanting to be better better selves
than they were yesterday
so uh when does this film actually come
out
October 20th October 20th field Max yeah
um what is next for the for the two of
you do you work together on a lot of
projects
we've been working together for a long
time so yeah we look into the next one
for sure
um yeah do you think you would do
anything on this subject matter again
um I think humans pursuing
um greatness and people pushing their
limits
so I think you know our our the next
film that we're we're really
um jumping into now is is is
um looking to
kind of feature
someone who really um pushed their their
boundaries in order to accomplish
something that they had in their mind
that they they needed to do in this
world
um and you know helping to share those
stories as
um
and all the complications that come in
yeah
it's very complicated yeah but it's
similar concept one character kind of
putting themselves against their
capabilities in the universe and the
complications that come with it yeah we
still have some work to do before we can
talk about it so yeah
well I'm looking forward to seeing it
you converted me to
things about uh racing in space it was
it's a fascinating film and I really
enjoyed getting to know Jesse
uh and really you know celebrate her
accomplishments
um which are amazing and uh thank you
you know uh good luck to you guys and
thank you so much for for coming to talk
about the film
thank you appreciate it thanks for
having us
[Music]